und jetzt das heute journal
wer für die demokratie streitet der hat
mich auf seiner seite
wer sie angreift wird mich als gegner
haben da will einer kämpfen und er weiß
dass er streiten muss der alte und neue
bundespräsident hat heute womöglich die
rede seines lebens gehalten ein appell
und ein plädoyer gerichtet nach innen
und nach außen
guten abend in allen eine große mehrheit
der bundesversammlung hat frank walter
steinmeier heute gewählt für weitere
fünf jahre als unser staatsoberhaupt das
war keine überraschung wie deutlich er
sich gegen drohungen von innen und außen
wandte das war's schon den russischen
präsidenten mahnte steinmeier namentlich
die wahl eines bundespräsidenten und das
war noch nie eine präsidentin ist seit
gründung der bundesrepublik eine
besondere zeremonie wir sehen hier noch
mal alle bisherigen amtsinhaber das amt
verkörpert die einheit des staates so
hat es das verfassungsgericht deren
rolle beschrieben das staatsoberhaupt
wird nicht vom volk direkt gewählt aber
wie bei seinen vorgängern auch war das
heute eine bunte mischung in der
bundesversammlung
fußballtrainer und katholische nonnen
ortsbürgermeisterin und schlagersänger
eine ex kanzlerin und ein amtierender
pakets wiedemeier berichtet es sind
ungewöhnliche zeiten und so war heute
nicht so wie sonst bei
bundesversammlungen alle kandidaten
saßen abseits ganz am rande abstand
halten so die vorgabe krone bedingt
tagten die über 1400 delegierten nicht
im plenarsaal sondern im größeren paul
löbe haus verteilt auf fünf etagen die
demokratie funktioniere betonte die
bundestagspräsidentin in ihrer
eröffnungsrede um gleich darauf auf das
eigentliche thema dieser tage zu kommen
den konflikt zwischen der ukraine und
russland
nutzen wir alle möglichkeiten der
diplomatie
um die gefahr eines krieges zu bannen
jeder krieg kennt nur verlierer
es sind nicht nur
bundestagsabgeordnete die heute das neue
staatsoberhaupt wählen durften auch eine
ehemalige
bundestagspräsidentin und ehemalige
kanzlerin landes und kommunalpolitiker
sowie zahlreiche personen des
öffentlichen lebens die von den ländern
entsandt werden waren dabei
das ich mir als westfälischer metzger
gesellen sohn erlauben darf am
ästhetischen tischler sohn mein
vertrauen auszusprechen und der welt
oder den leuten zu sagen hey so
funktioniert unser land in dem wir uns
andere bundespräsidenten wählen das
finde ich toll das ergebnis dann keine
überraschung fast eine dreiviertel
mehrheit für den alten und jetzt auf
neuen bundespräsidenten überraschend
deutlich dann jedoch steinmeier in
seiner rede oft wurde ihm vorgeworfen
nicht deutlich genug seine stimme zu
erheben heute hat er es getan sprach
zuerst über die außenpolitik ich habe
lehrern präsident putin lösen sie die
schlinge um den hals der ukraine suchen
sie mit uns seinen weg der frieden in
europa bewahrt frieden müsse immer
wieder erarbeitet werden im dialog wo
nötig aber auch mit abschreckung und
entschlossenheit so steinmeier sein
zweites thema demokratie er will sie
verteidigen
nach innen und nach außen ich werde als
bundespräsident keine kontroverse
scheuen demokratie braucht kontroverse
aber es gibt eine rote linie und die
verläuft bei hass und gewalt und diese
rote linie müssen wir halten in diesem
land meinen namen
ausdrücklich dankte steinmeier seinem
gegenkandidaten dem mediziner gerhard
trabert dessen thema die lage der
ärmsten im land werde auch er künftig
mehr aufmerksamkeit schenken mehr tun
für soziale gerechtigkeit genau das
erwarten auch viele der delegierten
an den bundespräsidenten habe ich
wirklich die erwartungen mehr soziales
engagement gezeigt wird das eben die
spaltung zwischen arm und reich diese
schere wirklich diese kluft überwunden
wird fläche und auch mit einigen worten
wieder die verbundenheit in der
gesellschaft herzustellen klare ansagen
die heute genau das versprach steinmeier
dann auch am abend in der zdf sendung
was nun klare ansagen ganz sicher man
kann sie nicht jeden tag machen man muss
darauf achten dass man gerührt wird
deshalb habe ich immer sehr darauf
geachtet dass ich als bundespräsident
nicht als der tägliche besserwisser
wahrgenommen werde zurück zur
bundesversammlung am ende übrigens war
abstand halten kein thema mehr irgendwie
war es dann doch fast so wie früher vor
corona
zwei die heute mit gewählt haben bei der
bundesversammlung in berlin sind jetzt
bei uns wiebke exner ist friseurin aus
glinde in schleswig-holstein ricardo
lange intensivpfleger aus hoppegarten in
brandenburg an sie beide guten abend
hallo schönen abend sie sind ja nicht
zufällig dabei gewesen die eine hatte in
der pandemie deutlich weniger zu tun
frei extra 17 wochen haben sie gar nicht
arbeiten können der andere deutlich mehr
jetzt hat der bundespräsident in seiner
rede heute frust enttäuschung
gereiztheit in der deutschen
gesellschaft ausgemacht vor wie haben
sie das ganz persönlich erlebt
für mich war das eine sehr anstrengende
sehr bewegende zeit ich habe hier zu
hause zukunftsängste nebenbei gehabt wie
geht es weiter mit unserem job was
machen wir wann geht es wieder los meine
tochter war im homeschooling es war eine
sehr anstrengende und aufregende zeit
und waren eigentlich war wieder
glücklich als ich wieder arbeiten durfte
ja sie sagen jetzt war haben sie den
eindruck dass wir das schlimmste
überstanden haben sehen sie jetzt einen
neue perspektive für sich oder haben sie
da immer noch
probleme also ich denke mal dass wir das
schlimmste was unseren beruf an der
friseure überstanden haben da wir ja
eigentlich zum gesundheitswesen
mittlerweile von der sache wir sollen
uns nicht mehr schließen und ich hoffe
dass es auch wirklich so bleibt dass wir
weiterhin offen bleiben und ich kann mir
eigentlich auch die mir vorstellen dass
wir noch mal so ein lockdown machen wie
wir ihn vor
letztes jahr hatten erlanger sie sind
bekannt als wortgewaltiger stimme ihres
berufsstandes jetzt waren heute viele
menschen aus dem gesundheitswesen dabei
bei der wahl mit absicht ist das aus
ihrer sicht das richtige ein gutes
zeichen oder würden sie sagen dass es am
ende doch wieder nur kosmetik
also zeichen hatten wir in dieser
pandemie was unsere berufsgruppe angeht
ja genug wir wurden ja praktisch wohl
juristisch vor jeder kamera linse
gezogen und die pflege war ja in
zeitungen fernsehen überall vertreten
passiert ist leider nix und von daher
ist es für mich heute auch kosmetik aber
ich hatte das große glück ich hatte
herrn lauterbach erhaschen können und
habe ich natürlich zu seinem neuen amt
gratuliert habe auch ganz klar und
deutlich gesagt dass es so nicht
weitergehen kann und dass ich unbedingt
etwas ändern muss in unserer branche
haben sie konkrete antwort bekommen vom
bundesgesundheitsminister
dass ihnen bewusst ist und so und ja
aber wir hatten nicht soviel zeit war er
sehr gefragter mann braucht dieser
veranstaltung aber zumindest konnte eben
nochmal nahelegen dass ich ja was ändern
muss der bundespräsident hat heute
gesagt ich will orte besuchen an denen
menschen verluste erleben das war so was
wie eine agenda für seine neue amtszeit
wohin sollte er unbedingt kommen
projekte
ich finde er sollte einfach zu vielen
verschiedenen bereichen gehen es ist ja
nun nicht nur ein bereich sondern wir
haben ganz ganz viele die wirklich unter
dieser pandemie gelitten haben und er
soll weiterhin an alle denken im
einzelhandel die auch mit dieser zweig
plus geschichte im moment ja nun sehr zu
tun hatten oder zwei geschichten und ich
finde das ist alles ein denken an die
gesamte bevölkerung
verlangen was uns trennt sondern
wirklich an uns kleineren ja herr lange
wo würden sie den bundespräsidenten in
den nächsten jahren sehr gerne sehen
ja wie die damischen sagt in der
bevölkerung denn die partie war wie ein
brennglas und hat nicht nur bei uns
pflegekräften sondern bei der ganzen
bevölkerung tiefe narben eingebrannt und
wir reden die ganze partie immer von
systemrelevanten berufen ja das sind die
menschen den wir in der innenstadt
erklärt wir können unsere haare
schneiden wir können unsere ware über
das fließband schienen ihr könnt unter
wasser hin reparieren aber hier in der
stadt wohnen könnt ihr nicht weil das
privileg habt ihr nicht denn die mieten
sind für euch leider zu teuer wird am
rande der stadt wohnen und das ist für
mich auch eine gesellschaftliche
spaltung die man nix mit corona zu tun
hat sondern einfach nur mit arm und
reich frau extra sie haben heute frank
walter steinmeier gewählt sie haben
gesagt der mann tut unserem land gut man
kann ihm vertrauen woran machen sie das
fest sie kennen ihn ja gar nicht
persönlich
ich mache es eigentlich aus der ganzen
zeit in den letzten fünf jahren wo in
der medienwelt oder als bundespräsident
ja nun war sehr viel für meine meinung
für die bevölkerung für das land für das
außenministerium tätig war immer
vermittelt hat auch mal klartext gesagt
hat mit halterin worten so geht es nicht
weiter
und das hat mich einfach von ihm
fasziniert und ich hoffe einfach dass er
so weiter macht und uns auch in der
nächsten
runde ist genau so weiter macht und dass
wir auch dort vermittlung haben auch
gerade ukraine was alles jetzt im moment
auf uns zukommt und das ist halt einfach
so es macht ihnen für mich menschlich
herr lange ich nehme an sie haben frank
walter steinmeier nicht gewählt sie
waren heute für den linken kandidaten
gerhard trabert da glauben sie denn dass
auch steinmeier von seinem
gegenkandidaten heute etwas gelernt hat
also wir können ja über alle voneinander
lernen und ich kannte den ehrentreffer
bevor diese bundesversammlung auch gar
nicht aber nicht so ehrlich aber habe
ihnen herr kennenlernen dürfen und er
setzt sich viel für obdachlose ein für
die schwachen der gesellschaft und ich
finde da können wir uns alle ein
beispiel dran nehmen wir müssen alle
viel mehr füreinander da sein und wenn
herr steinmeier sich da was abgucken
könnte wäre das super zwei die heute den
bundespräsidenten mit gewählt haben
wiebke exner und ricardo lange ganz
herzlichen dank dass sie heute bei uns
waren heute schon mal
gerne vielen dank dass wir da sein
dürften
die first lady der bundesrepublik
übrigens wünscht sich keine wirkliche
zweite amtszeit elke büdenbender will
zurück in ihren job als richterin
zumindest in teilzeit ich liebe meinen
beruf sagt sie und ich vermisse ihn auch
ihr mann hat heute eindringlich gewarnt
wir haben schon darüber berichtet vor
der gefahr eines von russland
entfesselten kriegs in osteuropa morgen
startet der bundeskanzler eine
vermittlungsmission nach kiew und moskau
von der manche sagen dass sie die letzte
chance sein könnte die lage heute
beschreibt christian sen auch im
dorfladen von michael murat hof in der
branche reden sie über das
militärmanöver dass belarus und russland
gerade auf der anderen seite der grenze
abhalten dobry janka der ukrainische
grenzort würde eine russische invasion
als erstes spüren diese angstmache höre
ich nur im fernsehen und im internet
aber mehr auch nicht es gibt keinen
grund sich sorgen zu machen
kundinnen valentina benz macht sich da
schon mehr gedanken vor allem wie man
wladimir putin zur vernunft bringen
könnte
vielleicht das europa sanktionen
verhängt denn wie kann man sonst noch
einfluss ausüben und dass vielleicht die
menschen in russland aufbegehren denn
das will doch niemand da gibt es doch
auch normale leute die keinen krieg
wollen und dass ihre kinder in den krieg
ziehen
einen krieg mit den nachbarn in der
ukraine wir fragen in moskau was die
russinnen und russen darüber denken ich
hoffe dass sich alles zum guten wendet
aber von putin ist nichts gutes zu
erwarten er hat völlig den verstand
verloren
das hätte konsequenzen
viele menschen wären betroffen
es würde viele opfer geben und in einer
katastrophe enden
und während russlands militär die
muskeln spielen lässt laufen weiter die
drähte heiss in der krisendiplomatie und
die usa erneuern die warnung vor einer
russischen invasion aber ohne konkrete
beweise vorzulegen
wir glauben dass es jetzt jeden tag zu
einer größeren militäraktion kommen
könnte und wieder kommen diese
einschätzung aus einer vielzahl von
quellen und nicht nur vom geheimdienst
morgen reist bundeskanzler scholz zuerst
nach kiew und dann weiter nach moskau
mit dem ziel klare ansagen in hinblick
auf das was passiert im falle einer
militärischen aggression und
gleichzeitig alle wege nutzen die
möglich sind dafür dass es zu einer
friedlichen entwicklung aus der krise
herauskommt und dass russland die
situation deeskaliert und in der ukraine
wie hier in odessa bereiten sich
freiwillige weiter auf das szenario vor
von dem alle hoffen dass es nicht
eintritt
und jetzt haben wir weitere wichtige
nachrichten an diesem sonntag und die
hat hanna und da schauen wir zuallererst
auf die korona zahlen genauer auf die
sieben tage incidents die ist zum ersten
mal seit wochen rückläufig und liegt
heute bei 1400
66,5 und auch die zahl der
neuinfektionen sinkt und zwar seit zwei
tagen das robert koch institut meldet
heute
125.000 160 neue fälle und damit 8013
weniger als vor einer woche es kamen
außerdem 58 todesfälle hinzu
einen aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus den hat heute
bundesinnenminister in nancy faeser
angekündigt die finanzströme von
extremisten sollen ausgetrocknet werden
das sagte fischer der bild am sonntag
außerdem sollen ihnen konsequent die
waffen entzogen werden derzeit sei der
rechtsextremismus die größte gefahr für
die demokratie sagte die ministerin
in dresden wurde heute der opfer der
luftangriffe im zweiten weltkrieg
gedacht am abend setzten hunderte mit
der traditionellen menschenkette ein
zeichen für frieden und versöhnung und
außerdem gegen die vereinnahmung ihrer
stadt durch rechtsextreme kurz vor ende
des zweiten weltkriegs hatten alliierte
bomber teile dresdens in trümmer gelegt
und 25.000 menschen starben damals
die schweizer regierung wollte private
medien eigentlich mit einem neuen
millionen paket unterstützen doch die
schweizerinnen und schweizer sagen nein
bei einer volksabstimmung heute sprachen
sie sich mehrheitlich gegen die
staatliche förderung aus sie sollte
zeitungen und privatradios helfen
außerdem war eine volksinitiative gegen
tabakwerbung erfolgreich überall dort wo
kinder und jugendliche sie sehen können
ist die werbung nun verboten also zum
beispiel auf öffentlichen plakaten oder
im kino die regierung hatte sich gegen
ein solches verbot ausgesprochen
und nun zum fußball in der bundesliga
verlor am nachmittag union berlin klar
mit 0 zu 3 gegen borussia dortmund der
bvb hat damit den abstand auf
spitzenreiter bayern verkürzt die sg
hoffenheim und arminia bielefeld
trennten sich am abend zwei zu null
so und jetzt bei uns ein lustiger
sexfilm das ist die sehr plumpe version
einer anmoderation aber da ist was
wahres dran die zeitungen schreiben das
exakt so über den neuen film mit emma
thompson und sie selbst stargast auf der
berlinale sagt wir sollten mehr über
sexualität reden reden und über die
liebe denn auch dazu ist eben doch noch
nicht alles gesagt im kino unsere
filmkritikerin sabine schulz erlebt
gerade einen wettbewerb auf der
berlinale wie es ihn noch nie gab noch
nie gab es so viele filme von frauen
über frauen im wettbewerb der berlinale
regisseurin nicolette krebitz und
hauptdarstellerin sophie rois gehen für
deutschland ins rennen
ihr film hat den skurrilen titel
das schneller alphabet der liebe die 60
jährige anna hat schon glanzvollere tage
als schauspielerin gesehen nun gibt sie
dem 17 jährigen adrian sprechunterricht
doch dabei wird es nicht bleiben
die reife dame und der junge mann zwei
außenseiter die auf konventionen pfeifen
eine amour fou wie man sie selten auf
der leinwand sieht
natürlich habe ich jetzt auch speziell
dieses ungleiche paar gewählt
weil es für mich selbst am
provokantesten ist und weil es mir neue
fragen stellte ich wollte was von liebe
erzählen und und eben nicht nur von
gesellschaft und vom klischees und
rollenklischees und dann von einer
wirklichen begegnung eine begegnung der
temperamentvollen art emma thompson
bringt zu was sie park die stimmung zur
kobe gebeutelten berlinale auch sie
spielt eine frau um die 60 mit einem
jüngeren mann nur ist ihr liebhaber ein
callboy mit therapeutischen fähigkeiten
spielen sie 62 für religionslehrerin
seit zwei jahren verbindet sie hatte
noch nie einen orgasmus sie merkt dass
ihr etwas fehlt ist mit ihrem leben
nicht zufrieden
zwei menschen ein hotelzimmer ein
kammerspiel zwei meter lässt auf
denkbare gleich geld nennt sie in die ex
lehrerin hat aus internet fundstücken
eine liste zusammengestellt was sie
alles mal ausprobieren möchte sie vieles
schnell hinter sich bringen
es ist ein künstlich vergnügliche ein
psychologischer schlagabtausch denn leo
der charmante sechs arbeiter versucht
sie aufzulockern zu entspannen sie mit
sich und ihren zweifeln zu versöhnen
auch mit den zweifeln an ihrem perfekten
körper
90,9 prozent der frauen schämen sich für
ihren körper jeden tag sind wir von
diesen perfekten bildern umgeben so
sollte es auch du aussehen macht diese
diät macht jede übung dann wirst du so
aussehen nein das wirst du nicht wir
zerstören das leben der frauen mit
diesem scheiß und das muss aufhören der
film spricht das an
es sind die frauen die diese berlinale
prägen mit einem anderen einem
weiblichen blick starke frauen jeden
alters die eins gemeinsam haben die
liebe zum kino
und die ist ansteckend wie es weitergeht
in dieser welt kommende woche das zeigen
wir ihnen jetzt hier ist der heute
journal ausblick von björn seitner
[Musik]
um ein zeichen zu setzen für ein ende
von gewalt gegen frauen und mädchen
werden sich am montag weltweit wie der
menschen treffen und tanzen das motto
der kampagne one berlin rising eine
milliarde erhebt sich verweist auf die
erschreckende erkenntnis dass weltweit
jede dritte frau gewalt erleidet
keine zweig regel nur noch ffp zwei
masten im einzelhandel mancherorts sind
corinna regeln schon gelockert am
mittwoch werden bund und länder beraten
wie es im frühjahr weiter gehen soll
bundeskanzler scholz hat weitere
lockerungen in aussicht gestellt jetzt
wo der höhepunkt der mikrowelle in sicht
sei
am freitag wird in münchen die
sicherheitskonferenz beginnen 35 staats
und regierungschefs rund 100
ministerinnen und minister sowie die
spitzen von uno nato und eu werden
erwartet das beherrschende thema
russlands drohgebärden richtung ukraine
sprechen wird man jedoch nur über moskau
und nicht mit moskau denn auf sämtliche
einladungen nach münchen kam aus dem
kreml nur absagen
und jetzt noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten morgen ein meist
freundlicher sonne wolken mix von westen
im tagesverlauf dichtere wolken und
zeitweise regen dazu im norden ein
kräftiger südwestwind an den küsten mit
stürmischen böen es wird mild mit 7 bis
14 grad die weiteren aussichten am
dienstag nur im norden und an den alpen
niederschläge ab der wochenmitte wird es
dann deutlich wechselhafter mit viel
regen windig bis stürmisch die
temperaturen bleiben mit
wie schön
so damit schicken wir sie in dieser
nacht und morgen sind wir wieder für sie
da und die nächste heute express gibt es
hier gegen 0.20 von uns beiden
danke fürs zuschauen und tschüss
[Musik]